lima vous êtes devant le bataclan c'est
la houle attaque la plus meurtrière a eu
lieu il ya six ans mais des cérémonies
ont lieu ce matin dans tous les lieux
frappés le 13 novembre 2015
oui tout à fait légaux et grégory à
l'horreur réalité à une centaine de
mètres du bataclan puisque et bien les
cérémonies se tiennent dans l'intimité
des personnes touchées des cérémonies
qui suivent en réalité l'ordre des
attaques perpétrées ce soir du 13
novembre 2015 qui ont donc commencé ce
matin à saint-denis où les membres d'un
premier commando se sont fait exploser
aux abords du stade de france faisant un
mort les hommages aujourd'hui se sont
ensuite poursuivies dans les rues de la
capitale d'abord dans le 10e
arrondissement devant elle et terrasse
du bar le carillon et du restaurant le
p'ti cambodge c'est la cas 21h25 il y a
6 ans jour pour jour la première attaque
du second du deuxième commando
terroriste était perpétré un commando
composé de trois terroristes de 3,2
trois hommes qui ont tiré en rafale sur
ces établissements ainsi que sur
d'autres terrains cette fois ci du 11ème
du 11e arrondissement la brasserie la
bonne bière le restaurant italien casa
nostra la belle équipe et le comptoir
voltaire au total 39 personnes ont ainsi
été tuées ce soir là et puis à 21h40
c'est un troisième commando qui est donc
rentré au bataclan où doit commencer
dans quelques minutes une dernière
cérémonie à 100 mètres d'ici donc
toujours dans le 11e arrondissement le
soir du 13 novembre cette salle de
concert était bondée 1500 personnes
étaient venues écouter le groupe eagles
of death metal les terroristes sont
entrés ont tiré en rafales dans la fosse
avant d'abattre méthodiquement les
personnes restantes les personnes
allongées au fond au total le bilan de
ce carnage 90 morts lors de cette soirée
ce sont 130 personnes qui ont perdu la
vie dans l'attaqué terroriste la plus
meurtrière jamais commise en france
merci guy marosi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions vous êtes au
bataclan à paris merci également à robin
dubois qui vous accompagnent derrière la
caméra